joyeux anniversaire joyeux anniversaire c'est
beau l'homme qui a violé ta femme nous pouvons nous en
occuper pour toi qui es toi
nous ne sommes que quelques citoyens qui
demandent justice
mon violeur il est mort
cela ne te coûterait rien
financièrement on peut demander a  en votre faveur à
un moment donné dans le futur, cherchez
quelqu'un pendant quelques heures et quelque chose
qui nous aiderait oh attendez que
vous tombiez non ce n'est pas le mien oh bien sûr
mon cher il semble que vous ayez le paquet Je ne suis PAS
un tueur
[Musique]
c'est  question laisser ma femme la [ __ ] seule
promesse est une promesse d'accord mr.  mur Zack
j'ai besoin de te parler
pourquoi diable
nous ne pouvons pas aller voir les flics certains d'entre eux sont des
flics qui m'ont piégé pour le meurtre de
ce journaliste
l'organisation secrète un groupe qui
prétend rendre justice reviens je
veux  je te parle
heureux maintenant
tu m'as encadré n'oublions pas ce que nous
avons fait pour toi